today I'm here in seven itza but you get
my son Raja hi Morgan
it's a pleasure to meet you pooja
welcome what in the world happened here
so Morgan what actually happened here
it's a genocide this border of Serbia's
near ah very very very close they came
here they wanted to kill everybody and
just together to give this territory to
separate it from Bosnia
that's it decided to serve yeah yeah the
Serbian army collected all women men and
children into these factories over there
and from there they were separated and
man boys they were they took them all
around these mountains to kill them in
the [ __ ] from there they started to
the mass killing
you know 1,000 people at a time to mass
grave yard
nice clothes
soon after NATO bombing helped in the
war but it was too late to save the
victims of strepa need set so you were
five six years old I was six years old
and there were a lot of boys my age that
were killed that day here and I still
can't believe like how is it possible
for people to be blind because of their
own belief and how can they not see this
humanity it for me it's like an
unimaginable that exists people who can
do this kind of ethnic cleansing entire
family lines were wiped out here
[Music]